foreign
pieces of work you've been doing has
been leading several efforts to help
educate governments work toward better
laws and better regulation as the
relation AI we'd love to hear more about
that there is a culture in Silicon
Valley as we just keep making things the
law will catch up by itself but AI is
impacting human lives and sometimes
negatively we're talking about fairness
we're talking about privacy we were one
of the leading universities that lobbied
a bill called the national AI research
resource and this bill is calling for a
task force to put together a road map
for America's public sector is to
increase their access to resource for AI
compute and AI data it's not a
regulatory policy it's an incentive
policy to build and rejuvenate
ecosystems
thank you